انا المشاهدين بعد انتهاء اضرابات الثلاثه
ايام التي عمت نحو 60 مدينه ايرانيه عدد
زخم الاحتياجات مجددا الى الشوارع والمدن
الايرانيه بدءا طبعا من العاصمه طهران
التي رفع فيها المحتجون الشعارات التظاهر
في بعض محطات المترو وايضا في حافلات
النقل العام في الطرق المؤديه الى شارع
ازادي وانقلاب بالعاصمه اضافه لمدن ذات
الغالبيه الكرديه والبلوشيه والاذريه ومن
المحال والاسواق انتقلت الاضرابات
والاحتجاجات بقوه الى عدد من الجامعات
الايرانيات حيث نظمه طلاب بعض الجامعات
كجامعه امير كبير في العاصمه طهران تجمعنا
احتجاجيا رددوا فيها شعارات طبعا مناهضه
للنظام ايضا في جامعات بمناطق كردستان
وبروسستان والاحواز ردد المحتجون فيها
شعار المراه الحياه الحريه اضافه ايضا
لشعار الموت لخامي
[تصفيق]